le monde de la culture ne décolère parc
les professionnels du secteur estiment
que la culture est sacrifiée à paris
plusieurs dizaines de personnes occupent
toujours le théâtre de l'odéon ils ont
investi les lieux jeudi soir pour
demander notamment la prolongation de
l'année blanche pour les intermittents
ainsi que des négociations sur les
conditions de réouverture des lieux
culturels
bien décidé à rester sur place tant
qu'ils ne seront pas reçus par le
premier ministre ils ont tenu une
nouvelle assemblée générale cet après
midi à l'extérieur nouvelles
manifestations
écoutez sa réaction je pense que tout le
monde est conscient de ces problèmes je
pense que c'est pas du tout une lutte
contre le virus tout le monde luttent
avec contre contre en ce moment mais
simplement c'est dire pourquoi pourquoi
la culture aucune perspective pour
l'instant c'est on dirait que c'est un
c'est un monde qui a été rayé de la
carte depuis un an lorsque les
restaurants et les
les bars ça va repartir extrêmement vite
tout le monde la culture les spectacles
vivants les salles de spectacle ça
risque d'être beaucoup plus trop
problématique la demande qui est faite
auprès du gouvernement c'est celle de
prendre des mesures ad-hoc pour que le
secteur du spectacle vivant et des arts
vivants des imaginales puisse continuer
de vivre
il ya une interrogation sur la poursuite
notamment de cette sauvegarde notamment
concernant la question de l'aide des
intermittents du spectacle donc c'est
c'est à cela que les acteurs attendent
des réponses précises
évidemment